suddenly the impeachment of Donald Trump
is no longer top of Washington's
political agenda how long that lasts
will be determined by how Iran responds
to the killing of Qasem Soleimani for
now the president is still in Florida
and reveling in the success of the
military operation while his Republican
congressional allies back in no man
alive was more directly responsible for
the death of more American
servicemembers and Qasem Soleimani but
predictably at the very start of an
election year leading Democrats fret
about the consequences and question the
timing Joe Biden campaigning in Iowa
called it throwing dynamite into a
tinderbox
while his rival Bernie Sanders went
further Trump promised to end endless
wars tragically his actions now put us
on the path to another war potentially
one that could be even worse than before
700 extra troops have already been sent
to the region this week and more than
three thousand are being deployed
President Trump will deny that escalate
in his long simmering dispute with Iran
is connected to electoral politics but a
video recorded in 2011 attacking
President Obama was shared widely on
social media our president will start a
war with Iran because he has absolutely
no ability to negotiate he's weak and
he's ineffective so the only way he
figures that he's going to get reelected
and as sure as you're sitting there is
to start a war with Iran after he
authorized the killing of Isis leader
Abu Bakr al-baghdadi Trump gloated about
the details of the mission while taking
questions from the media but not this
time
his supporters in Congress have been
praising his decisive action but frankly
hardly an Americans had heard of Qasem
Soleimani until after his death this
won't resonate with the public like the
assassination of Osama Bin Ladin and it
carries much greater risk to u.s.
security and if what happened at Baghdad
Airport ultimately costs American lives
could impact Trump's re-election
campaign